another day another browsing the
Internet bring with it
now
now hey shad vitro
it's another one level one are you Shh
[ __ ] me man all right I can go find out
I'm a little duckling what the [ __ ] am I
doing here
what the hell is this that is Easter
bring me two for elephant tusks and I
really help you so I guess we have to go
this way man look at them graphics the
improvements of this game [ __ ] me oh
[ __ ] all right chill man I'm sorry about
that thing hey I'm so sorry mister the
hey whatever your name is I'm sorry can
I be the pastor well [ __ ] what
is that star get it it's trying to help
it
why go ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] haters man go go go go oh
no not an elephant dancer
Sugoi Sugoi elephant yeah it's a
disgrace
misfit dance yeah the rub wait all right
what do we do now what do I do with
these elephants [ __ ] I don't trust
them
all right I don't Oh buddy hit like this
all right I got it I got it I got it I
just jump on the [ __ ]
what is that dope what does that do oh
god this why why why why why why why
Oh what your elephant is gonna do about
my noose what are these nobody they
fights don't fly stop flying [ __ ]
I gotcha elephant test what else do you
want yeah I got him fry I got up there
pretty cool right all right
trick to you get raped
life does not start with death life ends
with this game come down it's the local
minimum blend of tape a fasting for
quite them [ __ ] hipsters no-oh-oh-oh
who's gonna get ranked
that's [ __ ] one more [ __ ] to rake
where is he he said it would help me
what do I do
what do you want okay so we're back in
this hellhole of a [ __ ] game I wrote
to the developer I can not [ __ ]
progress the first goddamn level so you
told me there's two ways to do it I
can't even figure why the one he says I
can jump a pass the black guy but the
black guy jumps inside me alright
elephant [ __ ] s many fake da hand it
back that I know how to do it and I
can't even do it the developer says go
left to the black guy with a shop yeah
it's [ __ ] right I can chill here hey
wait can I jump over no I can't
great just [ __ ] great yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah is this a [ __ ] joke if
someone just trying to make my life
miserable oh I came so far I need a
checkpoint you [ __ ] elephant
[ __ ]
I chant beware of Mines alright well
come here you [ __ ] you go on the Mike
Wolfe give me AK day
Oh again alright oh oh oh cool I broke
the game
fine fine it's not like I've been trying
for like [ __ ] outwards to progress
god I hate you
I am fine I'm fine I'm not fighting over
here what the [ __ ] is up with that what
is all right cool
this looks great got more cool uh just
what is that all right where do i how do
i tongue ah ah how do I do this yeah
whoa
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah no what
are you want from me one man fights in
heaven hmm
that's how it's done baby hedgehog
[ __ ] come down here fight me oh
[ __ ] are they anyway Jesus Christ all
right what do you want
there you go I [ __ ] your mom how about
that it's not so [ __ ] funny anymore
is it
well then Wow that welly welly welly
well sure bender
oh you share baby [ __ ] a lot of
a smile or do you a killer spear laughs
why am I getting progressively worse at
this game I know I'm acting like a 12
year old but if you play this goddamn
game you'd be doing the exactly the same
I have to jump on the red one while he's
not [ __ ] the Hedgehog yeah yeah obz
they are constantly [ __ ] look at him
where did you go
alright now now might be a good chance
yeah hey Big John's [ __ ] guys what the
[ __ ] is going on the checkpoint is right
there I don't understand I don't
understand I guess I have to time in on
the red one to jump up higher it's the
only thing I can think of and now it's
my chance yeah